-Unwind your mind
as we journey deep into
the mystic forest
realm to discover...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello, hello, hello, hello,
hello, hello, hello, hello.
I am Goat Leg Greg.
And this is "Pearls of Wisdom
with Goat Leg Greg."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Gilvin of the Tree,
show yourself.
♪♪
-It is I, Gilvin of the Tree.
[ Recorder plays ]
Commence thy pearls, Greg,
enlighten us with your thoughts
on "The Golden Bachelor."
-There once was a man
named Gary
who was looking
for a woman to marry.
He scored a big feat
in the Fantasy Suite,
for a little blue pill
he did carry.
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Good one, Greg.
The truth is what thou speaketh.
Now...
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Ruminate, if you will,
on Elon Musk.
-You really must go
to the dentist sometime.
[ Recorder plays ]
Elon Musk. Elon Musk.
Few can say they're richer.
Bought X to be cool,
but in the end, you're a fool,
because I'm still
calling the Twitter.
[ Laughs ]
[ Recorder plays ]
Aye, quite right.
-That's me laughing
through the recorder, Greg.
You sayeth what the rest of us
merely doth thinketh.
Oh, tell me,
thy most Goat Leg Greg,
what do you think
of "Five Nights at..."
[ Laughter ]
-I cannot understand
a bloody word you're saying.
[ Laughter ]
Can you repeat that, please?
-Tell me what do you think of...
-Thank you.
-..."Five Nights at Freddy's."
-Right. Here we go.
"Five Nights at Freddy's"
is freaky,
with plenty
of jump-scare moments,
but if you want to get freakier,
just go to the theater
and see "Beetlejuice"
with Lauren Boebert.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Recorder plays ]
-You know it to be true, Greg!
Hark how your musings
shine like so much raindrops
perched upon the plumpiest
blades of petulant --
come on -- morning grass.
Bravo, Greg! Bravo!
I say bravo to you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Gilvin, enough, enough.
-Okay.
-It is time for my final pearl.
-Whoo! The final pearl!
The final pedal!
Commence thy final pearl, Greg.
Do this...
[ Laughter ]
Do this one about...
Ew.
[ Laughter ]
Do this one about
the 2024 presidential race.
-Biden and Trump,
they might face off,
but I say enough is enough.
We're done with you two.
Let's elect someone new.
It's time for you both
to [bleep] off.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was it! That was the one!
You did it, Greg!
You did it!
Goodbye, Greg! Goodbye!
-Farewell, Gilvin.
And farewell to you all.
This has been "Pearls of Wisdom
with Goat Leg Greg and Gilvin."
[ Recorder plays ]
-Stick around.
We'll be right back with
Brian Cox, everybody.
Come on back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪